Pues bien lo había dicho Oscar lizzer el
alcalde de El Paso Texas que estaban
preparados para lo desconocido porque se
presumía se esperaba que llegarían
marejadas con altas concentraciones de
migrantes en los diferentes puentes
internacionales de la frontera que
Estados Unidos comparte con México pero
no fue así quizás uno de los cuadros
donde se vivió mayor afán y
desesperación ocurrió en Matamoros
Tamaulipas de alta concentración de
migrantes cruzando el Río Bravo pero en
otras ciudades Como por ejemplo aquí en
Ciudad Juárez no se vivió esa alta
concentración la única puerta que estaba
disponible para cruzar de un lado hacia
el otro era la puerta 42 paradójicamente
del mismo nombre de el título 42 y
fueron muchos los migrantes que se
concentraron antes de la medianoche para
lograr cruzar sin embargo después de la
medianoche cuando expiró Este título 42
decenas cientos de ellos quedaron en ese
Limbo atrapados entre un alambrado de
Púas y un muro me se dice entonces en
teoría que estos migrantes que cruzaron
el Río Bravo que atravesaron el cerco de
podas pues lo habrían hecho
irregularmente de manera que ya el
título 8 entraría a operar sobre ellos
prohibiéndoles la admisión al país por
lo menos cinco años Así que muchos otros
están esperando hacerlo por la vía legar
por la vía de la aplicación cvp One y
que no tengan este problema de ser
expulsados a sus países de origen Andrés
Ustedes han estado allí desde mediados
de esta semana han tenido la posibilidad
de hablar con varios de los migrantes
que fueron deportados durante el título
42 a México quienes denuncian malos
tratos en los centros de detención
migratorios del paso en Texas qué dicen
exactamente
bueno justamente frente a la puerta 42
llegaban muchos migrantes ayer jueves
que querían cruzar del otro lado pero
que nos contaron que ya lo habían hecho
en otras oportunidades son migrantes en
su mayoría venezolanos que llevan por lo
menos dos meses en Ciudad Juárez
intentando una y otra vez cruzar hacia
los Estados Unidos pero rápidamente son
aprendidos por la guardia nacional o por
la patrulla fronteriza entre lo que
denuncian son malos tratos primero en el
momento de la prevención en los cuales
los agentes utilizan la fuerza y
violenta para esposarlos según ellos
varios han tenido el brazo descolocado y
luego cuando los llevan a estos centros
de detención otra de las denuncias es el
hacinamiento porque son lugares que
están preparados para 90 personas pero
donde pueden llegar a entrar más de 400
480 migrantes allí otra de las denuncias
que hacen
de la suciedad los baños están en muy
mal estado y el tema de la comida que es
poca pero que para muchos de ellos les
genera somnolencia como si dentro de la
comida hubiese algún somnífero y
finalmente otro de los temas que
denuncian es que son separados de sus
esposas de sus núcleos familiares una
vez los deportan a territorio mexicano
ya no tienen como encontrarse con ellos
Porque además les votan todas sus
pertenencias incluidos sus teléfonos
celulares y así quedan divididas
familias frente a una frontera sin saber
dónde están y sin saber qué va a pasar
con ellos en un futuro